je peux pas venir demain problèmes de
boulot du lot parents je vous appelle et
pise
ça fait un an qu'elle est parvenu cette
info tout ça elle s'en fout de nous et
toi tu dis rien on aurait dû aller ça
fait combien de temps que tu est parvenu
à paris regarde papa remontant à
l'époque images savais pas du tout celle
d'émigrer
ce qui l'est également
8 il est rentré chez moi c'est la
mélasse et sa voix là bas je suis désolé
mais les plus chez nous tu as vu quelque
chose toi mais la vérité
bien on traverse et sur trottoir en face
à
bien
deuxième coaching
d'ailleurs c'est pas mal
[Musique]
c'est non pas la gérer papa c'est bien
de savoir quand il va pas les habitudes
d'un pétard maintenant vous croyez pas
comment ça c'est une grande fierté vis à
vis non un travail plus fidèles à la
demande de son père passer plus tard un
défi pour opter de vous renseigner ne
sera pas là avant 22 heures et pourrait
pas emmener la petite un faudra bien
tout seul
je cherche ma fille va
tyla c'est papa
je sais pas ce qui se passe je suis à
paris un casseur je ne trouve pas
sur colère soit nanti leïla
je sais que tu as que l'école je sais
pas ce que tu fous et j'arrête pas à
croire
ce qu'on m'a dit à ton club je veux tu
me rappelles
actu l'aide faut pas l'abandonner
[Musique]